this is a production of Cornell
University hello my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student of Cornell
and I am with I'm Chris smart I'm a
vegetable pathologist at Cornell and
today we will talk about one of the most
common problem problems that we can see
in a curbit field and it's powder meu so
we have Chris here so Chris can you tell
us a little bit about this problem and
what is it and how we can recognize it
absolutely so as Kenzie said powdery
mildo is one of the most common diseases
that we see on cucurbit and that's
whether it's in a farmer's field on a
pumpkin field or zucchini squash field
or in your own backyard let's start to
talk a little bit about powdery Milos in
general um they get their name uh
because they give the leaf a very
powdery look and people will recognize
this because you see it on almost every
type of plant there is importantly the
fungus that attacks cucurbits is
different similar yet different from the
one that you might see on your Lilac or
your peie or any of the other plants
that you're growing there's a powdery
mdeo that attacks almost every plant
that there is anything that we can do in
order to control or monitor yeah so
let's talk about what we're seeing first
and if you look at this Leaf here um you
see this white powdery ex uh
appearance and it almost looks like
someone has shaken powdered sugar onto
onto the leaf itself uh what what you're
actually seeing are the spores of the
fungus so this fungus has a very unique
life cycle you can't grow it in culture
in the lab which is pretty unusual for
plant pathogens you have it has to grow
on plant tissue like a Le Leaf surface
so uh the fungal spores like these here
one Spore will land on the leaf and
it'll actually germinate and penetrate
into the cell of the leaf and that's how
it lives it actually essentially sucks
the juice from the plant
so knowing that um it's you what you see
on the leaf here are the spores but the
actual body body of the fungus itself is
inside the leaf you know you asked about
oh are there you know what what do we do
how do we recognize it there are there
are diagnostic tools but really powdery
Milo is one of the easiest um diseases
to to identify in terms of control
strategies powdery Milo is somewhat
different from some other plants because
it actually prefers the healthiest
leaves on the plant so some some
diseases uh do best when you know the
plant uh the bottom leaves start to
sesse or or there's a wound powdery Milo
really likes that healthy leaf and the
reason is because it needs those healthy
cells to get its energy so if you if the
if you give if you give the plant too
much nitrogen and you have so many
leaves I mean this this cucurbit plant
has a lot of leaves here you know that
actually benefits powy MW um are we
going to see these mostly in like
younger or older leaves or it will be
distributed even and is are the leaves
the only ones that get the powdery or
can we see it in the stems of the plant
how um how is it distributed so in in
cucurbit you'll see it on the leaves the
pedals of the leaf like I'm just going
to pull this one right off um you can
see there's powdery Milo on the pedal of
the leaf right there and you'll also you
can also see it on the stem
of in particular you see it on pumpkin
fruit and it's a huge problem in pumpkin
uh if there's powdery Milo on the stem
that handle of the fruit gets weaker so
when people go you know you're at a
upick pumpkin farm and it's awesome and
you go to pick up your pumpkin and the
handle breaks off and no one wants that
and usually that's due to powdery mdeo
are we going to see any rotting over the
fruit uh whenever the disease is press
in no the only way you would see rotting
H you know the powdery isn't really
going to attack the fruit the way you'd
see rotting is if the powdery was so
severe that um the leaves you lost the
leaves and then the fruit could get Suns
scalded and then once it gets uh scalded
by the sun then you can get secondary
rots that might come in well pruning the
dis the diseased leaves will help um for
the
disease so if if you prune early enough
I mean anytime you get an oculum out of
the field you're going to
reduce the chance of spreading but with
powdery mildew there are so many spores
that it's really really hard to control
by taking out the leaves um you know th
this plant itself you know probably has
a million spores on it and this Leaf
isn't even that coated so it it's really
hard and and you know there's you can
see it the powdery MW just starting
right there and you know you know that
the fungus is is already inside the leaf
so taking off the powdery mildew
infected leaves it isn't going to be the
best strategy for controlling this
particular disease if there if there was
one leaf that was completely coated in
powdery mildew and the rest of the plant
had a lot less I would probably take
that off and get it out of there um but
in a especially in a large field
situation that that's a tough thing to
do so is there anything that we can do
for example are there varities that are
less susceptible to powder Milo
yes there are and there are um there are
cavars that uh have a k muu resistance
Gene and our lab actually is working
with a breeder at Cornell Michael
mourich and his lab uh has different
cultivars that are resistant and he's
actually trying to breed that resistance
into winter squash um there's already
some resistance in melon and some of the
other cucurbit great is there any other
thing that you will um like to tell us
about the disease or yeah um so powdery
mdeo is is also somewhat unique in that
it it does best when there's high
humidity but not free water on the
leaves so when when there's water on the
leaves the the canidia of powdery Milo
are actually quite fragile they um they
don't do well in water uh but if there's
high humidity they just Thrive so
finding ways to keep the humidity down
is very helpful so in a in a really
rainy year you tend to see less powdery
mildew uh however if you're in a garden
scenario and it's a dry year going out
and hosing down your plants once a day
is actually just going to increase the
humidity so that would probably increase
the powdery MW um other things that
um that uh uh girl will do is um that
you know there are control strategies
lots of uh different control strategies
for powder mildo uh because the fungus
produces so many spores one of the
things that is fairly common especially
in well in all powdery milus but in
cucurbit powdery mildew for sure is
fungicide resistance so Growers are
really careful about rotating Fungicide
chemistries and making sure that they're
only using products that are going to be
effective against the powdery Milo
that's in their field in the hom
Gardener situation um you might hear a
lot of folks talk about uh baking soda
or other things to apply to plants and
there are commercially available
products that are very similar to baking
soda and um those can be effective
against powdery mildew uh especially on
a on a small scale if if I am a farmer
let's say I have a a lot of like corbits
on my field does this spacing will
affect uh the absence or presence of the
disease yeah so any anything you can do
to to reduce the humidity you know in
inside of a very Lush plant will help
but because the the Canadia can fly a
really long way it's spacing isn't isn't
going to help as much as you know as it
would with other diseases so these
Canadia um certainly can fly uh
throughout this field and to other other
cucurbit fields in the area and then one
once they have the powder me do it will
they can blow in they blow in the wind
and they can blow in the Wind from there
so this uh mainly transmitted by the
wind is there any insect that we can see
that can transmit the disease or only um
wind um wind is the wind is the major
way that the the passenger gets around
there are um it can overwinter in your
soil and I don't I don't see any here
today but sometimes if you have a very
thick patch of powdery Milo like this
you'll see black dots inside of it and
those are called uh casasmith thesia and
those chth thesia um are actually the
the overwintering structure of the
powdery mildew and those uh will fall
into the soil uh if this Leaf debris is
left in the field it'll get tilled in um
and and they will release spores in the
spring and that's frequently how this
might get started so you recommend at
least getting get rid of like old plant
debris in the field yeah if at all
possible getting rid of plant debris in
the field um and um you know just
getting anything that's diseased out of
your field will be a big help okay
thanks chis so we just learned about
part deio if you need more information
or want learn more about vegetables go
to the Cornell vegetable website and you
will find a lot of information there
thank you thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu